foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
against a government that is maybe legal
but not legitimate a government that
wants to
break down Israel's democracy after the
laws that they're planning to pass
Israel will continue to exist but not as
a democracy they want to curtail the
Supreme Court's power
[Music]
first time the time uh going out
something like demonstrate but it's not
a real Democratic demonstration it's a
the main reason of protect my family my
grandson and I hope that many people
will come in the next six or one year to
do the same that's the only way we can
fight this
criminals and governments
Netanyahu is also weaker vis-a-vis the a
potential position both internal
domestic opposition for example
opposition that comes from the economic
Elite of Israel the high the high-tech
industry which is very important in
Israel or the military Elites it's also
a potential opposition and also
opposition from the International
Community such a position or or if
Netanyahu promotes measures that will
provoke a severe a conflict with the
International Community especially the
us but also the the EU
in such a case if such a position might
harm the economy and the security of
Israel it might affect Netanyahu it
might impact Netanyahu at least to delay
some of the more problematic measures
like the override closing others